nous abordons à l'article 2 un sujet
central de nos problématiques de société
qui dépasse le seul cadre de la loi sur
les retraites le travail des seniors le
travail des seigneurs c'est la
reconnaissance de leur long engagement
professionnel c'est la reconnaissance
l'expérience inégalée et d'une expertise
qui ne sont pas en France suffisamment
reconnus la France et le 16e pays de
l'OCDE sur 27 donc c'est un digne d'un
pays comme le nôtre la France doit se
doter rapidement d'une politique
publique forte en la matière mais si on
regarde la réalité en face il faut
constater que le travail des seniors
s'améliore depuis des années 25%
d'amélioration entre 2000 et 2020 et le
plus haut depuis
1975 il est certain que l'association va
encore s'améliorer par deux facteurs
d'abord l'amélioration du marché du
travail depuis 2017 a créé une tension
favorable sur les offres d'emploi et
profite naturellement au Seigneur et
ensuite la réforme que nous allons
discuter elle-même en allongeant la
durée du travail va mécaniquement
favoriser le travail des seniors comme
cela a été observé dans tous les pays de
l'OCDE et en France notamment depuis la
réforme de 2010 mais nous ne pouvons
nous contenter de ces seuls facteurs il
nous faut agiter les mentalités influées
sur elle il faut que les entreprises et
la volonté de faire une vraie place au
Seigneur il faut que les politiques
publiques proposées favorisent cet élan
c'est cela notre responsabilité
politique c'est la raison pour laquelle
le Mouvement démocrate se félicite de
l'index proposé dans cet article 2 mais
souhaite aller plus loin par
l'instauration l'instauration d'un vrai
système bonus malus qui va bien sûr
favoriser les entreprises vertueuses et
inciter celle qui le sont moins à le
devenir nous proposerons également une
obligation de négociation triennale d'un
accord collectif d'entreprises afin
d'engager des actions concrètes en
faveur des seniors car nous croyons à
l'intelligence du dialogue social pour
régler cet enjeu mais au-delà des qui
seront débattus nous faut une politique
publique forte et donc nous appelons à
une loi dans les prochaines semaines sur
ce